Heute im Rasenfunk.
Der Blick auf Anderlein.
Fluminense gewinnt die Copa Libertadores, die südamerikanische Variante der Champions League und das zum ersten Mal in der Vereinsgeschichte. Wir wollen blicken auf dieses Finale und wir wollen blicken auf das ganze Turnier. Herzlich willkommen hier in der Ligatur des Rasenfunks. Schön, dass ihr eingeschaltet habt, liebe Hörerinnen und Hörer. Und schön, dass ich hier zwei Gäste begrüßen kann. Zum einen Johannes Skiba. Er ist freier Journalist, unter anderem für die TZ. Er kommentiert auf Sport total TV, er schreibt bei ihr Freunde und er hat den Podcast Goal Olympico. Und irgendwie habe ich den Eindruck, das könnte mit unserem Thema hier zusammenhängen. Hallo Johannes, schön, dass du hier mal im Rasenfunk bist.
Ja, hoffentlich sieht das dann sein neuer Nationaltrainer auch so. Oh, wait, könnte sein, dass das vielleicht eintritt, was du da prognostiziert hast. Andreas, ich weiß nicht, ob du was ergänzen möchtest oder ob du uns noch einen weiteren Shooting Star vorstellen willst.
Na, Joa hat ja schon sehr viele gesagt. Was mir auch noch bei ihm gefallen hat, war, dass er dann am Tag danach hier mit Motorrad, oberkörperfrei, ohne Helm durch die Favela gefahren ist. Das war natürlich auch irgendwie großartig. Ja, ich glaube auch. Ich habe so meine Zweifel. Der Schritt nach Europa bei ihm könnte natürlich auch wieder so ein Karrierebreaker sein, wie das bei so vielen brasilianischen Stürmern ist. Aber ja, hat mir auch sehr gut gefallen und ist definitiv der Shooting Style des Turniers. Da gibt es immer eine Meinung auf jeden Fall. Andre zum Beispiel, den kannte man ja schon, ein Nationalspieler. Geht jetzt wahrscheinlich zu Liverpool, Ines als Shooting Style. Also das passt ja nicht. Er ist der beste Mittelfeldspieler im südamerikanischen Clubfußball. Ihn kann man nochmal erwähnen, weil vielleicht viele Leute ihn nicht so kennen. Und er ist ja auch noch jung. Ansonsten bin ich zwar nicht so der Fan von dem Spiel, aber Valentin Barco einfallen von Bukka, der wahnsinniges fußballisches Potenzial hat. Der aber auch so ein verrückter, bunter Vogel ist irgendwo. Und der jetzt wahrscheinlich, ich gehe auch davon aus, dass der für Bukka kein Spiel mehr macht. Das Manchester City oder auf jeden Fall Premier League scheint es zu werden bei ihm. Der hat da eigentlich angefangen als Linksverteidiger. Ist aber, ich weiß nicht, ob ihr das gesehen habt, als in der Liga wurde er mal so richtig schön auseinandergenommen von Giacone, von so einem Flügelspieler bei Rosario Central, der nicht ziemlich abfeiert. Das ist so ein bisschen sein Problem. Er kann halt eigentlich nicht verteidigen. Der ist halt nach vorne, ist ja wirklich grandios und macht auch verrückte Sachen. Nicht immer so einfach, glaube ich, für die Mitspieler. Ist aber totaler Leader mit seinen 19 Jahren, glaube ich. Aber ich glaube, man muss bei ihm halt schauen, welche Position am besten zu ihm passt. Auf jeden Fall muss er mehr offensiv eingesetzt werden, weil ansonsten gerade in Europa, jeden Samstag, jeden Sonntag, jedes Wochenende, nehmen die den auseinander. Aber erst mal so als Fußballer, finde ich, ist er auf jeden Fall einer, der jetzt in der Libertadores auf großer Bühne gezeigt hat, dass er da ist, dass er halt auch in schwierigen Momenten, wo es bei Bukka nicht läuft, Verantwortung übernimmt, trotz der, sagen wir mal, Platzhirsche, die sonst auf dem Platz stehen. Und eigentlich, ja, der wahrscheinlich schon der interessanteste Spieler bei Bukka einfach ist, der beste Fußballer, den sie haben. Aber auch er, sehr schwieriger Charakter, aber Eier ohne Ende. Und diese Kombi aus toller Fußballer und geiler Präsenz macht ihn halt wahnsinnig interessant erstmal.
Aber ganz kurz, war Baku auch derjenige, der vor einer Ecke Ninho irgendwie mit dem Kopf in Ninho reinläuft und Ninho am Hals trifft und dann danach elf Meter für sich reklamiert? Oder war das jemand anders? Verwechsel ich das gerade.
So ein Rotthaarigeist, ich weiß gerade gar nicht die Zähne, die du meinst. So ein etwas nicht besonders groß, eher schmächtiger Typ.
Ich hab's mir irgendwo aufgeschrieben, ich finde gerade die Notiz nicht. War eine dieser kniffligen Szenen, ein kolumbianischer Schiedsrichter hat es übrigens gut gemacht, dieses Finale zu leiten, nicht so einfach. Und das war eine dieser Szenen. Also vielleicht war das Baku.
Aber er hat zum Beispiel beide Pässe gespielt in der ersten Halbzeit, gerade den auf Cavani, das war eigentlich die größte Chance, die Burka hatte im ganzen Spiel. Und er ist halt fußballerisch schon auf einem anderen Level. Aber trotzdem fand ich jetzt mal, er war trotzdem, unterm Strich war ich enttäuscht von seiner Leistung. Auch von Christian Medina, der ist auch ein Spieler, der mir eigentlich gefällt. Der ist aber auch nicht in diese Shooting-Stars. Aber Baku hat jetzt so, das ist halt auch wichtig, für europäische Scouts oder Entscheider zu sehen, wie präsentiert sich einer. Das kommt natürlich nicht gut an, dieses unfaires Spiel. Aber trotzdem, du musst in jungen Jahren, wie diese zwei Jungen, über die wir jetzt geredet haben, mit so einem Selbstvertrauen. Weil es geht ja immer darum, schafft es jetzt dieser Spieler, dieser Latino in dem Falle, schafft er das auch in Europa. Du brauchst einfach willensstarke, selbstbewusste Jungs. Weil es wird nicht immer alles so gut laufen. Nimm Kennedy zum Beispiel aus seinem Umfeld raus. Da kann ja alles passieren. Vielleicht ist das sogar gut für den. Und Baku ist halt auch einer, der muss mal in so eine europäische Top-Team. Und dann braucht er auch mal so einen Leader an seiner Seite, der ihn auch mal ein bisschen in die Schranken weist. Danach, auf dem Platz, wird er auch bei einem europäischen Top-Team einer der besten Fußballer immer bleiben. Aber es geht halt... Das ist halt auch ein Spieler, der geht vorm Tripling, stellt er sich auf den Ball. Solche Sachen auf der Bühne, Libertadores. Das kannst du ja im Grunde nicht machen. Ich meine, das ist ja fast schon Assi. Also, wenn nicht der Verteidiger, dann wirst du den einfach nur noch wegsensen. Aber der findet das auch geil, dieses Provokante. Und schnauzt dann halt auch solche Legenden wie Cavani an, wenn er der Meinung ist, der läuft falsch, der läuft nicht genug oder wie auch immer. Und das ist eine Qualität erstmal. Die muss man natürlich so ein bisschen managen. Aber der Junge hat eigentlich, wie man sagt, der hat kein Dach. Das heißt, der hat Megapotenzial. Aber, wie gesagt, ein bisschen zügeln und man muss für ihn seine Position finden. Und meine Meinung, die des Links-Verteidigers ist es nicht.
Er hat kein Dach. Was für eine schöne Formulierung. Die versuche ich mir auf jeden Fall zu merken. Ich wollte mit euch noch über eure Lieblings-Anekdoten von diesem Turnier sprechen. Ich bin mir aber nicht sicher, ob wir das vielleicht sogar schon mit den besten Spielen mit absolviert haben. Johannes, ist dir was darüber hinaus in Erinnerung geblieben, was wir jetzt noch gar nicht thematisiert haben? Das kann ja auch abseits des Feldes passiert sein.
Da muss ich ein bisschen überlegen. Mir ist noch eine Szene eingefallen, was auch tatsächlich immer wieder passiert und nicht unbedingt für den südamerikanischen Fußball spricht. Aber es war eine K.o.-Partie von International. Ich weiß aber leider nicht mehr, welches Spiel das war, da wurde einfach Tränengas ins Stadion eingedrungen, weil die Polizei das dann auch mal draußen gegen Fans eingesetzt hat und dann reingezogen ist, das Spiel wurde unterbrochen. Fans aus dem Block sind da so ein bisschen geflüchtet, ganz hektische Szenen. Es ging dann auf einmal nach 15 Minuten, warum auch immer, einfach wieder weiter. Aber es sind auch immer wieder natürlich so die äußeren Bedingungen. Vor zwei Jahren, wo die großen Proteste in Kolumbien waren, eigentlich dieselben Szenen. Also außerhalb des Stadions Riesenproteste, Polizeiaufgebot und auch das Tränengas ins Stadion. Das gehört halt auch dazu. Also so ehrlich muss man sein. Das war, was mir noch eingefallen ist. Ansonsten, ich weiß nicht, Andi?
Mir fällt noch ein, als es ja noch Absteiger gab in Argentinien, ist ja mal der Pokalsieger abgestiegen, Patronato, der als Pokalsieger natürlich für die Libertadores sich qualifiziert hat. Und natürlich nicht weitergekommen ist, aber zwei Siege geholt hat, aus der Gruppe, und das fand ich für einen Zweitligist, der personell total neu besetzt war, fand ich das schon gut. Dass man auch noch, vielleicht nicht mehr am 6. Spieltag, aber dass man zumindest noch kurz vor Schluss die Möglichkeit hatte, in die Südamerikaner als Gruppentritter reinzurutschen, das kann man noch mal erwähnen. Das war so meine kleine Mansion an der Stelle. Schade, ich hätte gerne die Mannschaft gesehen, weil die ja total, also Copa Argentina, Boca geschlagen, Riva geschlagen, und zwar nicht glücklich, sondern das war eine Maschiramannschaft, eine Pressing-Resistente, hohes Anlaufen und trotzdem irgendwie so eine Spielkultur. Die sind ja dann abgestiegen über diesen 3-Jahres-Durchschnitt. Die wären ja an sich nicht abgestiegen, wenn es jetzt normal ist, so wie wir das kennen. Abstiegsformat, europäisch, da wären die gar nicht abgestiegen in diesem Jahr. Das fand ich schade, dass sie dann mit so einer komplett neuen Truppe zumindest in eine leichte Gruppe reingekommen sind, aber haben ihre zwei Siege geholt. Das hat mich irgendwie dann auch so ein bisschen gefreut für diesen Provinzklub, will ich es jetzt mal nennen.
Aber kannst du kurz erklären, Abstieg über drei Jahreswertungen? War das jetzt wieder so etwas, was man sich ausgedacht hatte, dass …Ach so.
Das ist schon lange, das ist schon lange so. Du steigst über einen Koeffizienten ab. Da wird halt geschaut, wie viele Punkte machst du geteilt durch die Spiele. Und das ist dein Abstiegskampf. Also du kannst letzter werden und nicht absteigen, wenn du halt deine Jahre davor, deine ein, zwei Saisons davor, wenn die gut waren. Das ist halt auch wieder das. Das gibt es schon lange. Das schützt ja die großen Mannschaften. Weil jeder kann ja mal, so wie Schalke zum Beispiel, kann ja mal absteigen. Wobei, so wie Schalke gespielt hat in den letzten Jahren. Ja, aber das ist schon so. Du kannst ja mal ein schlechtes Jahr haben. Und dann rettet dich quasi der 3-Jahres-Punkte-Durchschnitt. Das ist halt auch so ein Ding, das gehört eigentlich abgeschafft. Das ist totaler Quatsch. Weil es dann halt auch für manche Mannschaften, wenn die dann sehen, ich werde nicht mehr Meister, aber ich steige halt auch nicht ab, dann ist die Saison fast schon gelaufen. Nutzen aber auch wiederum andere Clubs so. Vélez macht das immer mal wieder gerne. Dann schicken die so eine U23 aufs Feld, mal über mehrere Spiele. Das ist dann für deine Jugend, wenn die dann nicht so viel Druck haben, kann auch mal wieder gut sein. Aber letztendlich ist es totaler Quatsch. Und da wird ständig was geändert. Da ist auch manchmal gar nicht so einfach, up-to-date zu bleiben, weil aus ihrem Bauch. Weil zwei Fans nicht zu viel getrunken haben.
Aber wie ist denn das mit den Aufsteigern? Die haben ja noch nicht zwei Jahre da gespielt. Beginnen die dann bei Null? Und bei denen zählt dann der aktuelle Schnitt nur?
Ja, genau. Und der ist natürlich dementsprechend. Du kannst halt schnell hoch, aber auch schnell runter. Weil es ist wirklich deine Punkte geteilt durch die Spiele. Und das ist dann so mit ungefähr 1,0, 1,1, 1,2. Und da steigst du ab. 1,2 reicht wahrscheinlich noch, um drin zu bleiben. Aber das heißt, du kannst als Aufsteiger relativ schnell aus dem Abschicksam heraus, aber relativ schnell auch rein.
Und was ist bei Punktgleichheit? Oder geht es da quasi bis auf die letzte Dezimalstelle, die möglich ist? Weil das wird ja relativ oft dann passieren.
Ja, das haben wir jetzt eventuell. Wir müssen erst mal gucken, ob es denn tatsächlich Aufsteiger gibt. Vor einer Woche hatten wir vier punktgleiche Mannschaften. Wie wird das dann gemacht? Mit Halbfinale, noch mal Finale. Das ist alles. Auch das ist ja schon kurios, wie die Mannschaften absteigen. Und dann musst du dich mal da beschäftigen über diese National-W, die Zweite Liga, wie die aufsteigen. Wie kompliziert das ist mit diesen ganzen Finalspielen. Und dann der Erste gegen den Ersten und dann später noch mal da und dann der Zweite gegen den Achten. Aus der Zone, aus der anderen Zone. Katastrophe. Katastrophe.
Hört sich an wie Belgien. Da muss man mal herausfinden, ob das dieselbe Agentur ist, die damals Belgien und die Schweiz beraten hat bei ihren neuen Playoff-Modalitäten.
Mir ist doch noch eine Anekdote zur Libertadores eingefallen. Und zwar ein Rekord, der gebrochen wurde. Und zwar ein Negativrekord. Alianza Lima, also man muss wissen, der peruanische Vereinsfußball würde ich tatsächlich zusammen mit Venezuela als den schlechtesten Vereinsfußball aktuell bewerten. Bolivien hat durch den Heimvorteil immer wieder Mannschaften im Achtelfinale oder dieses Jahr sogar im Viertelfinale. Das ist schon besser. Und bei Peru ist aktuell nicht viel los. Und Alianza Lima hatte den Rekord, dass sie seit 30 Libertadores-Spielen kein Spiel gewonnen hat. 30. Also immer wieder qualifiziert für die Libertadores, weil sie ja in Peru doch die dominante Mannschaft sind. Immer wieder Meisterschaften gewinnen. Carlos Zambrano spielt da übrigens zur Zeit. Und dann haben sie es hinbekommen, ich glaube, es war sogar das zweite Gruppenspiel gegen Libertad aus Asuncion endlich mal wieder zu gewinnen. 2 zu 1. Nur um dann in der Folge wieder alles zu verlieren und als Letzter auszuscheiden und nicht in der Sudamerikaner auch noch teilzunehmen über den dritten Platz. Melgar, der andere peruanische Verein, auch Letzter. Also da geht nicht viel zusammen. Aber diesen Negativrekord, in Südamerika gibt es ja natürlich auch viele Häme immer. Also so ein Rekord mit 30 Spielen nicht in der Libertadores zu gewinnen, da wirst du ja auseinandergenommen. Das ist ja auch so ein bisschen das, was Fluminense jetzt geschafft hat. Du hast es ganz zu Beginn erwähnt. Von den großen 12 gab es ja nur zwei Vereine, die noch nie die Libertadores gewonnen haben, Botafogo und Fluminense. Jetzt ist es nur noch Botafogo. Schön für Fluminense und katastrophal für Botafogo, die aber nächstes Jahr in der Libertadores mit Sicherheit teilnehmen werden, sind gerade Tabellenführer.
Genau. Sind gerade Tabellenführer.
Ich will auch noch was sagen. Mir ist noch was eingefallen. Und zwar, im Finale haben wir, das war auch ein bisschen kurios, wir haben ja Vicente Taborda gesehen, der reinkam, der kam so die letzte Viertelstunde rein und hat ja dann irgendwie gefühlt 20 Flanken versucht, an den Mann zu bringen. Und das war, was da auch historisch war, das war sein erster Auftritt in der Libertadores. Also du machst ein Debüt im Finale. Das gab es zumindest in der Vereinsgeschichte, zumindest bei Boca gab es das nicht, kann aber in einem anderen Verein so gewesen sein. Was interessant ist bei ihm, er war ja ausgeliehen, an Platense, dann wurde er, wurde die Laie abgebrochen, weil er da gut performt hat und wollte ihn irgendwie in seine eigene Mannschaft integrieren. Hat ihn dann, ich glaube, er hat 200 Minuten gespielt insgesamt für Boca bisher, in der ganzen Serie, also in der Liga, bringt ihn aber dann im Finale, gibt ihm jeden Ball, also ich glaube, in der letzten Viertelstunde, da war ja der Border-Flanke, Abwehr, der Border-Flanke, Abwehr, die ganze Zeit, also gibt ihm diesen Hotspot in einem Finale, wichtigstes Spiel der letzten Jahre, um ihn dann, aber nach einem verlorenen Finale, ins Training der U23 zu stecken. Und das sind auch so Kleinigkeiten bei Boca, hier bei Riquelmes Boca, aber ich sage, was ist das denn für eine Scheiße eigentlich? Was macht ihr eigentlich die ganze Zeit? Also du bringst einen Spieler im Finale, der im Grunde keine Rolle gespielt hat das ganze Jahr bei dir, gibst ihm dann auch jeden, also diesen ganzen Protagonismus. So, hier, du bist jetzt mein Lifesaver im Finale. Und dann klappt das nicht und dann, ja okay, jetzt kannst du wieder zu U23 trainieren gehen. Weiß ich nicht. Ich lasse das jetzt mal unkommentiert.
Moment, du hast schon gesagt, das ist das für eine Scheiße. Ich weiß nicht, ob du es wirklich noch unkommentiert lassen kannst. Okay, damit sind wir ja auch schon so ein bisschen bei den Enttäuschungen des Turniers. Ich glaube, Riva haben wir schon rausgearbeitet. Johannes, die muss man da auf jeden Fall nennen. Oder überinterpretiere ich das jetzt?
Nee, auf jeden Fall. Auch wenn das am Ende unglücklich ist, das Ausscheiden der Anspruch von Riva ist immer –okay, wahrscheinlich immer –zu gewinnen. Das wird nicht immer klappen. Aber Achtelfinale hat nichts mit dem Anspruch von Riva zu tun. Und sind es ja auch eigentlich zu gut für, um da im Achtelfinale auszuscheiden. Flamengo natürlich auch, worüber wir vorhin kurz gesprochen haben, dass sie da in Asuncion rausfliegen, war auf jeden Fall so nicht zu erwarten. In der Gruppenphase waren es dann auch die Corinthians aus Sao Paulo, die dann auch schon früh rausgeflogen sind gegen die Argentinos, die Andi eben so schön gelobt hat. Das waren vielleicht die drei großen Enttäuschungen, würde ich sagen. Als Überraschung im Prinzip auch noch, dass das Bulli war, doch auch Atletico Paranaense rausgekickt hat, noch im Elfmeterschießen. Aber Paranaense ist jetzt auch nicht die Übermannschaft oder die große Supermacht im südamerikanischen Fußball. Letztes Jahr aber Finalist und dann war das Ausscheiden gegen den Bulli schon –also hat mich überrascht auf jeden Fall.
Andi, magst du da noch was ergänzen?
Man könnte noch Paulinho nennen, der Ex-Bayer Leverkusen, eine überragende Quali, so wie bei der Champions League auch. Gibt ja noch Qualirunden vor der Gruppenphase. Sieben Tore, vier Vorlagen in neun Spielen. Stark, stark. Dann der Spiel bei Minedo. Und dann im Achtelfinal gegen Palmeiras war keine Chance. Sind so torlos geblieben in beiden Spielen. Aber für einen Spieler, der hatte ja auch ein paar Kreuzbandgeschichten. Paulinho war ja einige Verletzungen dabei. Das war ja alles so ein bisschen sehr viel verbranntes Geld. Und wieder so eine Geschichte. Auch wenn ich natürlich immer für den argentinischen Fußball bin. Aber das tut mir dann natürlich auch leid. Dieses typische, da hast du einen Brasilianer geholt. Und da siehst du mal, Geld verbrannt, hat nichts gebracht. Und hat mich dann für ihn persönlich gefreut, dass er dann so überragend gestartet ist. Gut, konnten es nicht weiter ausbauen. Aber um nochmal, weil Leute kennen ihn ja noch aus der Bundesliga.
Er wird jetzt auch zum ersten Mal für die Seleção nominiert. Für die Länderspiele im November tatsächlich. Das ist ja auch nochmal so eine Sache, dass Fernando Dinis jetzt als Trainer in der Brasilianischen Liga und Nationaltrainer ist. Es sind jetzt doch überdurchschnittlich viele Spieler aus der Liga auch da. Also 1, 2 gibt es ja eigentlich immer. Meistens der dritte Torwart. Das ist jetzt auch der Fall. Aber dann wurde Paulinho jetzt das erste Mal nominiert. Enrique von Palmeiras. Andre natürlich, sein Fluminense-Mann Rafael Vega von Palmeiras. Hab ich noch jemand vergessen. Aber ja, das nur so als kleine Randnotiz. Also das ist, dass manche Spieler auch in jungen Jahren halt manchmal noch den Schritt tatsächlich nochmal zurück nach Südamerika machen können, machen müssen. Aber dann läuft es auf einmal wieder. Also es gibt ja viele Beispiele. Und Paulinho ist da sicherlich ein.
Hm, 23 Jahre ja erst alt. Dann habe ich noch eine letzte Frage, weil wir jetzt doch wieder bei Dienisch und der Selesao gelandet sind. Du hast vorhin gesagt, Johannes, dass er wahrscheinlich nur für ein Jahr Trainer bleiben wird. Aber ich dachte, das wäre eine ausgemachte Sache, dass er jetzt noch so lange Trainer macht, bis Carlo Ancelotti übernimmt.
Naja, solange –das muss man wissen –kein Vertrag unterschrieben, ist es alles möglich.
Aber es ist noch kein Vertrag unterschrieben.
Es ist noch kein Vertrag unterschrieben. Es ist der brasilianische Verbandspräsident. Er hat das in einem Interview schon so gesagt, dass Ancelotti Trainer wird. Ancelotti hat da meines Wissens noch nichts zugesagt. Auch wenn jetzt Brasilien im Oktober zu Hause gegen Venezuela verloren hat, auch Riesen-Blamage eigentlich. Deswegen kann es sein, dass sich da gerade der Vibe wieder ein bisschen ändert. Aber die Fernandes-Diniz hat eine Riesen-Unterstützung tatsächlich in Brasilien. Eben wegen diesem neuen Spielgefühl, was er da wegen diesen neuen taktischen Ansätzen und auch seiner Person, so seinen Umgang mit Spielern. Er ist ja gelernter Psychologe und hat auch einen ganz, ganz besonderen Umgang einfach mit Spielern. Weiß auch, wie er mit schwierigen Charakteren umgehen kann und das so alles in der Kombination. Für mich muss er der Trainer der Selesao sein, aber man will ja immer ein bisschen mehr. Und natürlich ist Carlo Ancelotti natürlich jetzt auch kein Trainer. Genau, das könnte natürlich auch klappen. Aber ich weiß nicht, mein Gefühl ist, dass Diniz Trainer bleiben muss. Aber wahrscheinlich wird es Ancelotti.
Wobei die Serie auch gerissen ist für Brasilien. Die Qualifikationsspiele waren seit 2015 oder 2016 ungeschlagen. Und jetzt gegen Bielsa und Uruguay haben sie verloren. Und gegen Venezuela nicht gewonnen. Was war das? Unschihen gegen Venezuela und gegen Uruguay verloren. Ja, werden wir mal sehen. Denn Denise hatte auch nicht überall Erfolg. Er kommt jetzt stark bei Fluminense, aber er hatte auch andere Stationen, die nicht immer so gut gelaufen sind. Ich sage mal, wenn du Ancelotti haben kannst, holst du. Außer er brilliert jetzt noch mit der Célizau. Aber ich weiß nicht, ob er vor dem nächsten Turnier die Möglichkeit hat.
Zeit hat man ja sowieso nicht in Brasilien auf der Trainerposition. Das ist ja absurd, wie oft die Trainer gewechselt werden. FC Santos hat jetzt für diese Saison bereits den vierten Trainer. Das ist natürlich in der Célizau noch ein bisschen konservativer. Aber Zeit hat es nicht. Und jetzt mit den Ergebnissen ist es natürlich auch kritisch. Und man will wieder Weltmeister werden. Und dann holt es am Ende doch wahrscheinlich Angelotti. Also das ist auch die wahrscheinlichere Variante, dass er da Trainer werden wird, um das nochmal so ein bisschen aufzulösen. Aber von der brasilianischen Spielidee und Spielidentität finde ich schon, dass das der richtige Mann ist.
Ja, interessant. Ich dachte, es wäre schon alles ausgemacht, so wie man ja auch schon dachte, es wäre ausgemacht, dass Xabi Alonso dann von Leverkusen zu Real Wechselt. Vielleicht sollten wir alle da, inklusive mir, einen Schritt zurücktreten und erst mal warten, bis Verträge unterschrieben sind.
Du hast recht, es wird auch überall so geschrieben, dass das in Stein gemeißelt ist. Und wie gesagt, dadurch, dass der Verbandspräsident das auch so gesagt hat. Also es gibt wahrscheinlich eine mündliche Vereinbarung, das wahrscheinlich schon, aber Vertrag ist noch nicht unterschrieben.
Okay, also dann warten wir das alles ab. Und ich empfehle allen Hörern und Hörern zwei Dinge. Zum einen werde ich in den Show Notes ein Video verlinken zum Fußball, den ihr spielen lässt. Relationism ist das, wie man es jetzt genannt hat, wurde von Malmö auch schon so zum Teil übernommen. Aber da gibt es ein paar sehr gute YouTube-Videos, die das gut erklären, was daran das Besondere ist. Und dann verlinke ich euch auf jeden Fall auch nochmal den YouTube-Kanal der Copa. Denn da kann man eben die ganzen Highlights nochmal sehen der Spiele, wenn auch leider nicht mit Kommentar. Das fand ich sehr schade an der Stelle. Ist mir doch egal, dass ich den nicht verstehe. Wenn er dann Goalschreit, dann spätestens setzt mein Verständnis wieder ein. So fremdsprachengewandt bin ich. Aber da kann man sich die Highlights nochmal angucken. Und ich werde mir unter anderem dieses Elfmeterschießen mit dem kaputten Elfmeterpunkt. Das werde ich mir jetzt nochmal geben, wenn das hier alles online ist. Ihr zwei, ich danke euch sehr herzlich. Ihr habt euch sehr, sehr viel Zeit genommen. Das weiß ich wirklich sehr zu schätzen. Ganz, ganz herzlichen Dank an Andreas Geipel. Add fun the Geip auf Twitter. Ich weiß nicht, ob du auch schon auf Blue Sky oder woanders bist. Noch nicht. Dann verlinke ich weiter deinen Twitter-Händel. Danke dir, Andreas, dass du mal wieder hier warst.
Sehr gerne, sehr gerne.
Und ebenfalls mit dabei Johannes Skiba, der add-Bayeres-jo, so heißt du, auf Twitter. Ich glaube auch aktuell nur auf Twitter aktiv.
Ja, ich habe schon Blue Sky-Account mir angelegt, aber den noch nicht bespielt. Also vorerst weiterhin auf Twitter unterwegs.
Ich werde dich natürlich auch verlinken. Und man kann bei Goal Olympico dich auch immer reden hören. Danke dir, dass du hier im Rasenfunk mit dabei warst.
Ja, sehr gerne. Dankeschön auch an Andi, auch an dich, dass wir hier mal endlich wieder so ein bisschen über Fußball Südamerika reden können. Es ist immer so ein Podcast, das ist auch immer so ein Ventil. Man hat ja Freunde, aber die wenigsten davon interessieren sich für südamerikanische Fußball.
Die kotzen über dazwischen. Beim Podcast kann man einfach so vor sich hin. Ich würde gerne Böseelzungen behaupten, das sei der Grund, warum es den Rasenfunk gibt. Also danke euch beiden und danke allen Hörerinnen und Hörern da draußen. Das hier war die Ligatur. Wenn euch das gefallen hat, unterstützt uns gerne. rasenfunk.de/supportersclub. Und schaut gerne auch auf rasenfunk.de, was wir sonst noch so für Sendungen machen. Also es wird morgen noch was erscheinen, zum zweiten Männerbundesliga zum Beispiel. Wir haben natürlich den Frauen- und den Männerbundesligaspieltag aufgearbeitet. Es gibt Borussia Dortmund Schwerpunkt. Alles am Montag erschienen. Also so einiges zu hören im Rasenfunk. Danke für eure Zeit. Danke für eure Aufmerksamkeit. Bleibt gesund. Bis bald. Der Rasenfunk lebt von euren Beiträgen.